So what do you do if you want to go to
the toilet. Well you had the opportunity
then of getting in that lift because it
wasn't crowded and not. A great number of
men waiting around to get into that left
to be taken up top and. You could go down
and do what you had to otherwise if the
lift was occupied. Well then it was
a long process of getting down
the girders right back down to
a level where. You could do
whatever you wish to. Think
. Do you remember any amusing incidents
while you were working on the route.
Well no particular items i think was
a general feeling though of great comradeship
to monks all the people and. Most of
the people had
a great admiration for the other
fellows who were working on the bridge
particularly i felt that the chaps who
have been doing the steel construction.
We're doing such
a wonderful job of. Dashing along girders
and jumping out onto her portion of metal
. Supported by the crane which was popping
around in the air and just balancing it
and taking it across and making sure that
it fitted in its position that it should
have and i felt that. They just amazed me
all the way along to see how agile they
were. And sure footed they were like
mountain goats. And i must say that i
always felt there should be great praise
for those fellows what you feel about
doormen long as an employer. Oh
i felt they were pretty good. I
had no great complaint from them because
it was the general working conditions of
the day that we were were having
there and generally of course.
Conditions were pretty poor you could say
that most building jobs. There were no
facilities if you wanted
a wash. There's usually
a tap somewhere around where they put the
hose on where they were using this to
do their concrete work or something of that
sort and most times you went home just
as dirty as you were on the job because.
There is just nothing in the way of
facilities and as for lunch rooms or anything
of that sort of course you just took
your lunch up on the job with you. And you
had it wherever you were we had to try
and get back to the road level.
And we'd sit there and have
a look at sydney and enjoy the view and eat
our lunch up there and think about the
things that were going to happen in the
future on that particular roadway in the
traffic dashing through and so
on. And it altogether. It was
a wonderful experience and i enjoyed
most every bit of it and i'd say that.
It's
a very pleasant memory to me to think back
over those days on the bridge. Did you
get sick pay or holiday pay. No
there was no sick pay day pay
. You just worked
a certain number of hours and your on by
the hour. And you could be put off with an
hour's notice so it was
a precarious way of living because
at any moment money could run out on
a job and. In the case of the
bridge of course there had been
a lot of the fellows had been working
there for many years before. Why start to
work on the bridge and they were in
a settled condition because they had proved
their worth and they were continuing on
the job but of course i was
a newcomer towards the end of the
bridge and. They had no real
reason for keeping me on because of
my experience on the bridge. I was
a an absolute outsider at that stage but i
was gradually taken in with the all the
others and got quite
a nice little run on the bridge of work.
When did you finish up. I finished up
before the actual roadway was
completed across the bridge.
It came to
a stage there where we were dependent
on cranes lifting our material up
and if they were in use by the granite.
Stone masons. Well then we couldn't get
a crane for our wood work and there came
times when it just became impossible for
us to work so that at one stage
there as things were gradually
going down in the way of. Construction
heavy construction was disappearing. It
became evident that somebody was going to
go off and several of us were told that
we would have to stand down which we did.
And i thought that was the end of it but
. Unfortunately i didn't come back and play
again because i felt that the thing was
tapering down and slowing down to
a point where there wouldn't be any other
people put on but i found out later that
they were looking for me and if i had shown
up. I would have had another job for oh
for about six seven months which i was
very unhappy about this but it was
the way of the employer at that time they
wouldn't get in touch with you had to get
in touch with them. And that's the system
that was working and i just. Made the
mistake of not keeping on.
And coming back again it's
a lesson i learned in later life and i
didn't do that sort of thing again. So what
happened to you then. Did you get a
job or will you go to work. I got
a job after about three months
and i worked around sydney on
some of the bigger buildings that were
going on around sydney and then that be
a break. I found that the if you were not
very well known. And i wasn't very well
known because i had finished an
apprenticeship with a firm which was
a victim of that particular period and
gone out of business which firm was that
that was
a beall construction company. And
it meant then that. You didn't have
people to go to where
you were known to get
a job so i found that any big building
that was near completion. There
are probably some thing on that building
that they want to get done and they'd put
a few extra men on just for the finishing
touches but it always meant that you were
on the finish and soon as you finished it
all you were out of work again. And that
was the general scene at that
particular time. And after
a few years of little jobs here and little
jobs there. I eventually went to work in
a job where i was employed for thirty
five years so i was quite settled in that
particular job. Before that were you ever
on the dole at any time. Well i i tried
the dole. But i was a single man
and i was given seven and six
a week. And i found that. That was quite
a problem to do anything for the seven
and six and i used to follow the
timber tracts. If i saw
a timber truck going around. I know he was
going to some building site and if he
didn't go too fast on my pushbike i wouldn't
be able to follow him and this is one
way of following up to get
a job. The the general conditions at that
time there was of sorts of strife
strikes going on small strikes on
jobs even though the conditions were
such that everybody is looking for
a job there had to be some control over
the way people are doing it because
. Only to the shortage of jobs. People
would try and put you on at less than the
award rates and there was quite
a bit of strife going on about
this. So having followed
a timber truck out to one
job and going to apply for
a job i found that it had been declared
black having peddled for miles because
there was one of these arguments going on
with that particular builder. So after
that. I wasn't so happy about following
every timber wagon that i got the
opportunity to when you've got the dole
was it coupons. Yes it was coupons
and the first thing we could go up to.
Just near the railway and central
railway station and you'd put
you coupons in. And you get
a sugar bag was. Low for
bread and dinner jam and
a few things like that that. Later
on it became money and you could go
down and pick up the money which seven and
six didn't do much either. When it was
coupons only what did you used to cook
with. Well i was living at home with my
mother at that time and other members of
the family and we used to cook on the gas
of course but. I was fortunate that some
of the other members of the family of
course were working. And we had to share
our resources. Yes the same thing would
apply to rent i suppose. Yes this was.
In the case of in my particular case. My
mother owned the house which was fortunate
but there were some terrible sets of
circumstances. I remember at one
stage where we applied i applied
for some assist some assistance and.
Inspector came out and just had
a look at the house and said. Oh now you
can put partitions across these rooms
there are large and let them. So
let us know when you do this and.
If you have any trouble then we might be
able to assist you but it's back to you.
You've got to do your own thing and some
people said to me that the fact that you
that you are somebody in the family had
a house or even furniture disqualified them
from getting the dole at all. Well this
. This could be i know in my case. When
i went to apply for it. There were big
hues on the walls that the key is where
the overseas terminal or just along from
where the overseas terminal is now. And
you got in these queues. And when you got
up to the table. It was generally at that
stage. They tell you you're in the wrong
here. So having waited about two hours
to get there and with no information
available until you got
to the table. It was
a very disappointing situation. So then you
get in the correct. Queue. And at that
stage they used to say
to me aright. Are you
a married man are you were
returned soldier married and with
a family you know i'm not right now are
you single return so you know i'm not.
Now what about are you
a married man now. And they go through all
these details and they'd get it down to
being
a single man and they'd say well. That
means we can't do much for you. Do
you have any money in the bank. Well
in during my apprenticeship. Which was
a very poor money i had saved
a bit and i presented my bank
book and they tell me then
that's it then when you get rid of what
you've got in the bank you come back and
say yes. How long does it take you to
get rid of what you heard and have been
didn't they glow after about
a month i was back on these queues
again and the queues they came right
along the wharf out and into the street
and there was two or three queues and
here's all these fellows waiting to go
along and what an experience. Do you
remember those queues well the bridge was
still being built. While you were in work
. No i don't because. At
that stage i suppose i was
that it lated to get
a job on the bridge.
And. Watching my my own
benefit of. Staying in one piece. I didn't
have much thought. I'm afraid for the
other poor fellows but. Hanging on up there
was the main thought i had each day.
How did you get to work. Where did you live
in the days only working on the bridge
. I lived it. At kingsford
it was then called south
a randwick and i used to go in the tram to
the quay and then catch the ferry across
to the north side of the bridge to work
there. One of the experiences that i might
tell you there is. The only jobs that
were available when you're out of work at
that stage seemed to be coming through
government departments and they would be put
in with any other jobs to the union but
you had to be at the union in the morning
for the morning call on the book where you
were registered. And you also had to be
there for the afternoon call. Now this
meant that the whole day was going to be
spent in town and during my
unemployment period. I used to ride
from south rendering up to kingsford on
a pushbike leave my pushbike there at my
sister's house and then walk up to high
street randwick which was the section and
get the tram to darlinghurst which was
a bad top and so i think at that stage and
then walk down from darlinghurst down to
the trades or to be there for the
morning call. The morning call
over you would spend some time around
town used to go to the town hall and sing
with all the others there the best things
in life for free. And all those sort of
things and have
a happy time in amongst all the stress
and probably have enough money for
a church to cake or something of that
sort something big. Cheap fear lunch. It
was
a chester cake. Well some of the fellows
used to say it was. The sweepings after they
had made
a few plum puddings and things was pastry
under an over it. I never did find out
but it did taste wonderful when you're
hungry. Hard times do you remember again
when you were on the bridge. What did you
do in your spare time when you had money
. Well i was
a radio enthusiast and when i had any
money. It went into my radio hobby. And i
was interested in radio amateur radio
transmitting and receiving and i was also
the secretary of the local radio club. And
this was the main enjoyment that i got
out of life at that particular time. You
didn't go to dances and such like an
evening. No i found that that was
a pretty expensive way of doing things
because. There are a lot of there's
a lot of money needed to compete and when
you're going around dancing and that saw
it it's amazing how much you can spend
and when you just do not have an income.
You just couldn't do much. I found with my
radio pads. I could pull them all apart
and rebuild them and having spent the money
on the first lot. I just built them and
rebuilt them and every time i saw
a radio paper. Most of the newspapers
of sydney at that time had
a radio section in it. So you get that out
and you'd build up the latest set of the
day and that would keep you going. And then
go around to the different radio clubs
. You'd be invited in didn't
cost you anything. And they're
a happy family of radio man and that
particular time is i was looking in the
newspapers there and i saw
drawings of how to build
a radio in the telegraph and all sorts of
odd funny. That's right. The telegraph
had
a lift out supplement with their radio section
at that time and most papers did because
it was so popular at that stage. They
just come up from the crystal set days to
valves that is and it was
a job that anybody who is
a bit handy could do. And today of course
most of these things are bought ready
built but we got
a lot of fun out of building them up and
putting up different aerial vs and trying
out different systems of long distance
communication the experimenters of that
particular stage laid
a foundation i think for future development
of. Particularly the high frequency
radio bands and. It was i was fortunate
that i was mixed up in that i think
i'd have gone crazy if i didn't have such
a hobby rather because only last amusing
story that you might tell us. Yes i think
one of the incidents that did happen
while i was working on the north through
a bridge for norman along.
Was. Firstly we had
a system of. On the office
at the ground level on
the north side they had a big board on
the left hand side. And everybody had
a disk that was hanging on
a hook. And the procedure was to take that
this guy off and go over to the right
hand side of the door this occurs on the
outside of the building. And place your
desk there and they would know then that
you were on the job. Well one morning
a chap arrived up top. To go into our work
gang and he had all these tennis players
on and a cappy belonged to a i'm sorry
a cricket club that's what it was and
he had all his gear on whites and so on
and he'd been to
a meeting. Apparently the night before and
it's gone through into the dough on and
he was able to get across and take his
disguise and put it on the other side of the
door get in the lift and go up but he
was quite shaky. So we thought that
say he was still under the influence.
We'd better do something to safeguard
him from falling off the bridge and also
so he couldn't cause any harm to the other
fellows that are working there. So. He
was lowered into inside one of the big
girders which were hollow. And he was in
an upright position near as left in there
to sleep it off. As long as there is
necessary. Round about lunchtime i got him out
and he was
a book there and he started work but.
This is always been in my mind as an
amazing thing that happened while i was
working on the bridge. So there we are now
. Leave it at that. Thank you mr. Brown.